il flottait comme une impression de déjà
vu dans les rues madrilènes en ce début
de semaine des parcs boucler des jardins
d'enfants déserté cent soixante sept
mille habitants supplémentaires de la
capitale espagnole sont invités à rester
chez eux à compter de ce lundi
au total ce sont désormais 850 mille
personnes qui sont concernées par le
confinement partielle de la ville
des milliers d'habitants qui ne peuvent
sortir de leur quartier qu'en cas de
nécessité comme pour aller travailler se
rendre chez le médecin ou emmener les
enfants à l'école
de nouvelles restrictions accueillie de
façon mitigée par les riverains cela
fait plus de quarante ans que nous
vivons ici pour les personnes âgées la
situation est critique nous devons
essayer d'aller de l'avant sans
enfreindre les règles j'espère que les
gens sont conscients de l'importance de
porter un masque et de respecter ce qui
nous a été demandé de faire ce que les
politiciens devraient faire plutôt que
de se livrer une bataille c'est de
trouver rapidement un vaccin
le bras de fer auquel fait référence et
habitants c'est celui qui oppose la
région de madrid et le gouvernement
central
ce dernier estime que les autorités
locales malgré l'élargissement du
confinement partiel à de nouvelles zones
ne vont pas assez loin et menacent
d'imposer des mesures drastiques dans
les quartiers les communes défavorisées
du sud de la capitale particulièrement
visé par les restrictions les
manifestations se multiplient avec un
mot d'ordre forcer le gouvernement à
investir davantage dans la santé
publique
ce que la région de madrid fait pour
combattre la pandémie est totalement
insuffisant ce que nous voulons tous
c'est que les ressources et l'argent que
détiennent le gouvernement central et la
région soit investi dans la santé
publique afin de la renforcer
nous sommes ici pour faire valoir notre
dignité en tant que population
nous sommes ici parce qu'ils nous ont
pas abandonnés et nous avons
l'impression d'être retourné dans les
années 80 quand les habitants mourait à
cause de la drogue et maintenant ils
veulent nous voir mourir du virus depuis
la résurgence de la pandémie dans le
pays
madrid est devenu l'épicentre des
contaminations à ce jour l'espagne
comptabilise plus de 700 mille cas et
plus de 31000 mort du coronavirus